the dceu has seen its ups and downs for
over a decade but the entire story goes
back hundreds of thousands of years
here's the complete timeline so far
around 200 000 years before the main
events of the dceu began to play out
Gods Ruled the Earth the deity Zeus
decided to create a new species similar
to the gods but Ares the god of war
interfered with Zeus's plan and
corrupted the newly made human race in
response Zeus created the Amazons and
all-female race of noble Warriors who
according to Queen hippolyta would
influence men's hearts with love and
restore peace to the Earth these two
civilizations lived together in peace
alongside the atlanteans for thousands
of years before the Earth was invaded by
Steppenwolf and his parademon army the
forces of Earth banded together and
ultimately managed to defeat and drive
out Steppenwolf and his forces although
he left behind three mother boxes when
he fled each of the three main races on
Earth took one of the mother boxes with
the intent of keeping them safe years
later the war of the Gods broke out in
which Ares killed all his fellow
Olympians but Zeus managed to create the
island of femascara for the Amazons
before he died he also fathered Diane
Anna with hippolyta although the child
was born after he passed away leaving
her with no knowledge of her true father
later Atlantis sank into the ocean and
the deserters left and formed their own
Kingdom at some point while all these
major events were playing out the
enchantress was born and imprisoned
alongside her brother Incubus plus the
dreamstone was created and The Wizard
Shazam imprisoned the seven deadly sins
in the rock of Eternity where he
remained to guard them
according to 2022's Black Adam around
5000 years ago the Middle Eastern nation
of conduct was the first major
civilization however it was ruled by an
evil despot named King Octon luckily the
Shazam and his fellow Council of wizards
granted magical powers to a young slave
boy named harout who led a proletariat
Revolution against the evil King this is
similar to what the wizard Shazam would
do for teenager Billy Batson centuries
later to protect and save his father the
weak-willed teth Adam her root grants
Adam his god-like Shazam Powers
unfortunately because her root is
temporarily de-powered at that moment
he's killed by a hidden assassin's Arrow
this enrages the newly superpowered teth
Adam and in his rage he murders King
Octon In Cold Blood he also loses
control of his powers and destroys a
large part of the Kingdom itself
inadvertently killing many innocent
people of kondok Adam is then stripped
of his powers by the Council of wizards
and is sentenced to be held in a magical
prison inside a secret cave in kondok
Forever
it's largely quiet on the gods and
superheroes front for the next couple
thousand years and then World War one
comes along the conflict draws in Steve
Trevor who while fleeing a skirmish with
the Germans crash lands on the hidden
shores of themiskira unfortunately
German soldiers follow and humans invade
the mascara for the first time a battle
breaks out on the beach and although the
Amazons are victorious hippolytus sister
and tayapi is killed in combat grieving
and convinced that Ares is ultimately
behind the Great War a naive Diana
decides to accompany Steve back to the
human world determined to root out and
defeat Ares and once I find them destroy
Ares the German armies will be freed
from his influence in the process Diana
winds up falling in love not just with
Steve but with Humanity itself she
enthusiastically Embraces much of what
human culture has to offer while
remaining true to her Amazonian Roots
although Diana is successful in
defeating Ares and ending the war Steve
sacrifices himself in the process Diana
Mourns his loss and decides to remain
among human permanently while continuing
to work as a superhero
on Christmas Day in 1974 a young
Thaddeus Savannah is on a drive with his
father and his older brother Sid when he
sees the symbols of the wizard Shazam
appear in his Magic 8-Ball thaddeus's
surroundings begin acting strangely and
he perceives that he and the car have
been transported to a strange new place
which turns out to be the rock of
Eternity there Savannah has his first
encounter with Shazam who tells him that
he's seeking a champion to inherit his
magic however Thaddeus proves himself
Unworthy of the Wizard's magic and he's
expelled from the rock of Eternity
thaddeus's resulting confusion distracts
his father which causes a car accident
as a result of all this Thaddeus vows to
one day find his way back to the rock of
Eternity and claim shazam's power for
himself several years later in 1980 the
baby Kalel is born to jorel and Lara
lorevan on the Planet Krypton shortly
before the planet's destruction kalel's
parents successfully managed to send
their son to Earth before the planet
implodes killing jorel and Lara along
with the rest of the Kryptonian race
several months later spaceship crashes
in Smallville Kansas where the baby is
discovered by Jonathan and Martha Kent
who adopt and raise him as their own the
following year Bruce Wayne's parents are
killed by a Mugger leaving Young Bruce
in the care of the family Butler Alfred
pennyworth
since the end of World War One in 1918
Wonder Woman attempted to operate in
secret although not particularly well
since she still publicly saves people
and takes down bad guys in extremely
flashy Ways by day though Diana Prince
works as an anthropologist at the
Smithsonian Institute using her lived
experience to inform her specialty in
ancient Mediterranean civilizations and
cultures there she meets her co-worker
the largely forgettable Barbara Minerva
who Sparks Diana's interest when the
hero notices the dreamstone in her
office curious to learn more about the
dreamstone Diana and Barbara begin to
form a friendship but everything goes
sideways when they both wind up
unknowingly making wishes on the stone
Diana wishes for Steve to come back
while Barbara wishes to be more like
Diana resulting in her receiving Diana's
Powers the stone eventually falls into
the hands of oil tycoon Maxwell Lord who
tries to use it to gain power and
success for himself by essentially
becoming the dreamstone Barbara then
allies herself with Lord who bestows
cat-like Powers upon her turning her
into cheetah ultimately though Lord's
plans collapse in on themselves the
dreamstone's power is lost and all of
its wishes are eventually renounced
including Steve's Resurrection as a
result he and Diana say goodbye yet
again
I pray that isn't true
there's a there's a wonderful big world
out there
after the chaotic events of the early
80s the second half of the decade is
much calmer although it still carries
some major developments in 1986 Arthur
Curry is born to human Lighthouse Keeper
Thomas Curry and the Atlantean Queen
Atlanta unfortunately while Arthur is
still a baby Atlantean guards attack the
curry home determined to return Atlanta
to Atlantis to marry King orvax Atlanta
is heartbroken and leaves her family
behind to keep them safe Arthur is then
raised as a human by his father also in
the late 80s Clark Kent begins to
realize he has superpowers as his powers
emerge and grow his parents urge him to
keep them to himself and they finally
tell him the truth about his Origins
Clark initially follows their wishes but
their desire to keep his identity secret
ultimately winds up leading to
Jonathan's death even though Clark could
have saved him around the same time
while Clark is discovering and
struggling to come to terms with his
powers Bruce Wayne adopts the secret
superhero identity of Batman and he
begins practicing his own unique brand
of Justice in Gotham
in 1990 NASA astronauts encounter an
alien creature floating in space the
creature has bright pink and blue skin
and is shaped like a starfish with a
single human-like eye in the middle of
its body once inside the shuttle the
alien starts attacking and killing off
the astronauts it has the ability to
release smaller duplicates of itself
that attach to a host once attached to
the creatures completely control their
victims nonetheless staro was eventually
captured by the United States government
which makes a deal with the corrupt
fictional South American government of
Corto Maltese in exchange for funds and
turning a blind eye to human rights
violations the Corto Maltese government
agreed to illegally house the dangerous
creature and experiment on it in a
secret facility dubbed yotenheim
meanwhile the Herrera regime that
controlled Cordo Maltese at the time
used staro to torture kill and control
political dissidents such as protesters
Freedom Fighters and independent
journalists the main scientist heading
the project was Gaius Greaves The
Thinker who has a comically large head
with brain enhancing cyber frenetic
sprouting from it Greaves abused staro
even derisively dubbing the creature by
its comic book name staro the Conqueror
as Bruce Wayne and Clark Kent each
circle their superhero Destinies in the
early 2000s other eventual heroes and
villains are just beginning to embark on
their origin stories Arthur Curry begins
training with Atlanta's advisor volko
working to unlock and hone his Atlantean
Powers so that he can one day take the
throne as king of Atlantis in 2004 Billy
Batson is born but he's abandoned by his
mother when he's four years old leading
to him being placed in the Foster system
at the time he believes that he was
accidentally separated from his mother
and he vows to find her again someday in
the late 2000s psychiatrist harleen
quinzel gets a job working in Arkham
Asylum and winds up falling in love with
her patient The Joker The Joker
convinces quinzel to help him Escape in
return for her efforts he subjects her
to electric shock therapy and pushes her
into a vat of chemicals which Alters her
physical appearance and mental state
after emerging quinzel adopts the name
Harley Quinn and she and the Joker
become two of Gotham's most notorious
criminals talk about a workplace where a
man's gone wrong during roughly the same
time frame archaeologist June moon is
possessed by enchantress while exploring
the Tres Osos caves in Peru
after wrestling with his mysterious
Origins for years Clark Kent finally
discovers his true identity in 2013.
that's when he goes to investigate a
mysterious object in Northern Canada and
finds the ruins of a Kryptonian ship
there he learns his true name Kalel and
he also meets Lois Lane using his powers
to save her life after finding the
answers he'd always been searching for
Clark Embraces his powers becoming
Superman soon after the Kryptonian
General Zod one of the few survivors of
the destruction of Krypton demands that
Clark be turned over to his care
concerned for the people of Earth Clark
voluntarily surrenders and Zod attempts
to persuade him to join him in his
mission to create a new Krypton on Earth
Clark refuses and battle Zod destroying
much of Smallville and Metropolis in the
process that includes the Wayne
Financial building where a nearby Bruce
Wayne looks on in dismay the destruction
wrought by kalel's battle with Zod fuels
Wayne's bitter hatred of metahumans the
battle eventually ends when Superman
kills Zod later Clark begins working at
the daily minute where he's reunited
with Lois who promises to keep his
secret
following the destruction of metropolis
and the public reveal of Superman Lex
Luthor and his company lexcor begin
looking into metahumans which leads him
to the discovery of Kryptonite in the
Indian Ocean Lex Corp soon begins
working to develop weapons technology
using Kryptonite and while this is
happening Lex throws a Gala for the
Metropolis Library reopening after being
destroyed in Man of Steel Bruce Wayne
Clark Kent and Diana Prince all attend
the Scala and meet briefly though none
of them realize the other's secret
identities later Bruce Wayne plots to
kill Superman using Kryptonite blaming
him for the destruction of metropolis
but before he can take action Lex Luthor
bombs the U.S capital during Superman's
Senate Hearing in the process of
investigating lexcor Bruce and Diana
discover the metahuman files which
include info on Aquaman Cyborg and the
Flash Bruce then attempts to carry out
his Vendetta against Superman but when
Lex Luthor creates Doomsday the heroes
team up to fight the monster together
doomsday is defeated by Batman Wonder
Woman and Superman but Kalel is kill
killed in the effort and a disgrace to
Lex Luthor is sent to Arkham Asylum
in the wake of Superman's death Amanda
Waller the director of the advanced
research group uniting superhumans known
by the acronym Argus becomes worried
that equally powerful but malicious
metahumans could become a major problem
for the United States in response Waller
gets the idea to assemble a team of
expendable super-powered individuals to
resist such a threat which he dubs task
force x these individuals are selected
from among incarcerated metahumans the
inaugural members of task force x are
Harley Quinn Deadshot Killer Croc El
Diablo Captain Boomerang and Slipknot
the team is led by special operative
Rick Flagg who's assisted by his
sword-wielding bodyguard Katana the team
is deployed in response to the
re-emergence of enchantress who also
releases her brother Incubus task force
x nicknamed The Suicide Squad by
Deadshot confronts enchantress and
Incubus but the group's disorganized and
Scattered nature leads to the team
nearly disintegrating however the
members eventually reassembled to fight
the supernatural villains and the
anti-heroes are ultimately Victorious
Rex flag kills enchantress freeing June
Moon from her possession and the rest of
task force x returns to prison with
improved conditions although the Joker
soon breaks Harley free
about 5 000 years after his previous
defeat Steppenwolf returns to earth in
search of his three missing mother boxes
he locates the first in semester and
attacks queen hippolyta and the Amazons
do their best to hold him off but are
unsuccessful hippolyta warns Diana of
steppenwolf's presence on Earth and
Bruce Wayne and Wonder Woman locate
metahumans from Lex corp's files
including Arthur Curry Victor Stone and
Barry Allen the group battles
Steppenwolf and Gotham but they're
unable to defeat him while Steppenwolf
attacks Atlantis to retrieve the
Atlantean Mother Box the newly formed
Justice League uses the third box to
revive Superman thinking he's the key to
defeating this overwhelming Villain at
first Superman has no recollection of
his former life but his memories
returned to him after seeing Lois Lane
he joins forces with the Justice League
and together they manage to defeat
Steppenwolf while the team is now all on
good terms they part ways each returning
to their own lives shortly thereafter
Lex Luthor escapes from Arkham Asylum
the son of Atlantean king or vax Marius
and Queen Atlanta Prince or Marius
attacks the surface World hoping to
unite the seven sea kingdoms and destroy
the land which he blames for his
mother's banishment has betrothed the
zabelian princess Mara opposes orm's
plan but can't get him to listen to her
so she heads to the surface to ask
Arthur for help together the two go to
Atlantis in search of the Trident of
atlan and their Journey eventually takes
them to Sicily there they fight Black
Manta who carries a grudge against
Arthur for refusing to save his father
when he was dying after narrowly
escaping Black Manta Arthur and Mara
continued their search for the Trident
leading them to the hidden sea at the
earth center there Arthur is reunited
with his mother and then goes to face
the mythical karathan who dubs him
worthy of the Trident giving him control
over the Seven Seas with his new power
Arthur defeats orm and becomes king of
Atlantis meanwhile in Philadelphia Billy
Batson is placed into the Vasquez foster
home and soon thereafter he's
transported to the rock of Eternity
where he's given the hours of Shazam
Shazam
yes carry my name and with it you carry
all my Powers although he's initially
confused Billy quickly adapts to his new
powers and basks in the excitement of
being a superhero around the same time
Thaddeus Savannah finally completes his
quest to locate the rock of Eternity and
unleashes the seven deadly sins upon
Philadelphia determined to stop him
Billy passes shazam's Powers onto each
of his foster siblings and together they
defeat the Demonic Baddie at some point
afterward Billy as Shazam meets Superman
and convinces him to stop by his school
for lunch with his best friend Freddie
Freeman
2019 is fairly low-key although a few
important events occur Captain Boomerang
escapes from prison making him the
second member of The Suicide Squad to
regain his freedom after the Joker freed
Harley in 2016. however Harley and the
Joker's romance is ultimately doomed the
two eventually break up prompting Harley
to blow up the ace chemicals building in
her distress meanwhile detective Renee
Montoya begins investigating Roman
Sionis owner of the Black Mass club and
a ruthless local crime Lord in early
2020 teenage pickpocket Cassandra Kane
is arrested by the Gotham City PD after
being caught stealing Sionis in turn
hires Harley to recover a diamond that
Cassandra swiped but realizing that the
young girl has swallowed the gem Harley
breaks her out of jail instead and waits
for her to pass the diamond she knows
Sionis and his henchmen won't be so
patient or merciful gradually Harley and
Cassandra develop a friendship and they
wind up crossing paths with Huntress
Black Canary and Renee Montoya coming
together to form an unlikely Alliance
together the group manages to defeat
Sionis and his henchmen killing the
gangster in the process later while the
five of them talk about staying together
as a group Harley and Cassandra go off
on their own and the remaining three
continue to fight crime as the birds of
prey
at the end of 2016 Suicide Squad we saw
the Joker rescuing Harley Quinn from the
clutches of Amanda Waller then we saw
her colorful Misadventures with the
ill-fated Birds of Prey at the end of
birds of prey we even see Harley and her
mischievous Protege Cassandra Kane
driving off into the sunset however it
seems not too long after her escapades
and birds of prey that Harley Quinn is
once again caught in the clutches of
Waller's task force x she's then sent on
A Dangerous Mission storming a beach in
Corto Maltese alongside her former
comrades Rick Flagg and Captain
Boomerang as well as a few others
however it's quickly discovered that
they were all just decoys sacrificed to
draw fire from the main group which
includes Bloodsport polka dot man
Peacekeeper and rat catcher 2. Harley
and Rick find themselves the only
survivors of the initial assault on the
beach though both eventually meet up
with the main team everyone then
discovers and fights off staro saving
the citizens of Corto Maltese after
Amanda Waller is subdued by her
underlings back at headquarters it seems
Harley has escaped The Suicide Squad for
good it
by 2022 conduct is no longer the
epicenter of civilization instead a
high-tech private military group called
intergang has taken over the struggling
Middle Eastern nation and its people for
their resources in this case the
fictional eternium teth Adam's magical
prison cave is eventually found by an
archaeologist and freedom fighter named
Adriana tomaz who summons Adam to save
conduct from the intergang paramilitary
group when Adam awakens Tomas is
attacked by intergang thugs Adam easily
destroys them then sets out to use his
powers to protect condoc teth Adam's
violent nature gets the attention of
Amanda Waller and the U.S government
which summons the Justice Society of
America to stop him the team includes
Hawkman Dr Fate cyclone and Adam Smasher
the heroes and anti-hero fight for a
while while a descendant of King Octon
takes control of an ancient magical
artifact that turns him into a powerful
demon named sabok teth Adam and the JSA
decide to put aside their differences
leading to the defeat of sabok but at
the cost of Dr Faith's life afterward
teth Adam who decides to go by Black
Adam is confined to conduct by the U.S
government with Waller threatening him
with the presence of Superman to keep
him in line
[Music]
we should talk
after the infamous War of the gods that
led to the death of the Greek pantheon
the defeated Titans took over in the
power vacuum this included Atlas whose
vicious tyranny eventually led to a
human Uprising the humans were helped by
the Shazam and the Council of wizards
who after defeating Atlas and the Titans
created a magical barrier between the
human world and the gods realm which was
left to rot unfortunately in the first
Shazam film Billy Batson broke the
magical staff that the Wizards used to
trap the Gods in an attempt to stop Dr
Thaddeus Savannah Batson succeeds in
defeating the villain but also erodes
the magical barrier between the gods and
man this leads to the daughters of Atlas
Calypso hespera and Anthea entering the
human world and exacting revenge for
killing their father Atlas together they
seek the fabled golden apple to sprout
the tree of life and create a new world
for the gods to reside in which would
kill all human life in the end Billy
sacrifices himself to stop the goddesses
and allows in Thea who Rebels against
her sisters to help Humanity to take the
golden apple and rebuilt her realm
luckily after being buried in the gods
realm Billy is resurrected by Wonder
Woman due to her demigod status she also
uses her power to fix the magical staff
the classic superhero The Flash is a
Speedster who wears a heat resistant red
costume and runs really really fast
that's because he can tap into what is
dubbed the speed force which allows him
to Sprint faster than the speed of light
his access to the speed force also gives
him the ability to vibrate his molecules
to phase out of traps heal super quickly
and even travel back in time furthermore
Barry feels that with his powerful time
traveling ability he can finally undo
the tragedy of his past that's why he
tries to prevent the death of his mother
and exonerate his imprisoned father who
was falsely convicted of her murder
however like all good time travel
stories his temporal Excursion leads to
drastic unforeseen consequences Barry
unwittingly travels to a different
timeline where Zod attacks a world with
no known metahumans Kara Zara as
Supergirl replaces Kal-El as Superman
and Batman is older and played by
Michael Keaton from the 1989 film Barry
also befriends and teams up with an
alternate World version of himself which
leads to obvious complications in the
space-time Continuum further furthermore
like the flashpoint comic book event
from 2011 that the flash is Loosely
based on his time traveling Adventures
will have a lasting and wide-ranging
impact on the whole DC Cinematic
Universe going forward
at the end of The Flash Barry Allen
realizes that going back in time to save
his mother has damaged the space-time
Continuum the damage is so bad that it
is eventually going to rip the
Multiverse apart and destroy everything
if he doesn't go back to make things
right we even see universes that include
the George Reeves Superman the
Christopher Reeve Superman the Nicholas
Cage Superman from the unmade Superman
lives film The Adam West Batman and many
more about to collide with each other
unfortunately in this case make things
right means Barry has to let his mother
die however while Barry does that he
makes one smell change that when he goes
back to the present allows his father to
be freed from prison unfortunately that
one small change has universe-wide
repercussions when he meets Bruce Wayne
in the present he's not played by Ben
Affleck or Michael Keaton but rather
George Clooney from 1997 Wins Batman and
Robin Clooney's Wayne seems to recognize
Barry but Barry is shocked and Confused
I freeze Batman
then in an after credit scene we see
that Barry has found Arthur Curry and
tries to explain his time travel
Adventures however Curry is
belligerently and comically drunk and
doesn't believe what Barry is telling
him Barry does mention though that all
the Aquaman he's seen so far look like
Momoa confirming that Momoa will remain
Aquaman even after James Gunn takes over
the DCU
foreign